[Music]
dr peterson thank you for joining us
my pleasure thanks for the invitation
absolutely so i want to dive right into
it i really admire you and i really
admire all of your work and uh and i
agree with very much of what you say
let's begin with ideology uh
you have said that ideology is a
parasite that's a sentiment i with which
i thoroughly agree
um you've explained the conflict between
ideology and traditional uh strains of
thought in the west
i think most people even on the right
even conservatives would find that
statement startling what is so bad about
ideology
well it provides a one size fits all
answer to every question
and there's a variety of problems with
that i mean and it's a one-sided biased
uh one-size-fits-all answer and the bias
depends on your particular ideological
stance
in some ways biases themselves aren't as
bad as you might think because they're
not that distinguishable from heuristics
which are simplifications that you need
to operate in the world i mean we can't
operate in the world as in
considering it in all of its complexity
we have to simplify it but there's
dangers in the simplifications and then
there's dangers in a consistently biased
simplification and ideologies are
consistently biased simplifications now
they're right sometimes so see part of
the reason that
the western democratic systems work is
because they allow people who have
specified biases to compete in an open
market of
biases what an election is
exactly exactly so you know sometimes
the right is right sometimes the extreme
right is right sometimes the left is
right so to speak and sometimes the
extreme left is right the extremes
aren't correct let's say very often
certainly not the extreme left yeah
sorry go ahead
but there you know there are situations
that arise where
less
generally applicable principles may
may sporadically hold but anyways the
point is is that in an open exchange of
ideas you get the opportunity for
multiple people to put forward their
biased heuristics their biased
oversimplifications
and to engage in the kind of debate that
raises the resolution of the question
and answer at hand
and that's necessary because the
environment is shifting underneath you
all the time and so what was right
yesterday what was correct yesterday
isn't necessarily correct today and so
you have to continually engage in
negotiation and discussion to stay
in the middle let's say in the in the
correct place yeah not to formalize too
much not to abridge too much and you
bring up there are ideologies on the
right uh we you know we see them they
change some pop up some uh fall out of
fashion but there has been a question
for a long time that conservatives have
debated
can a real conservative be an ideologue
or should conservatives ground their
their view of the world in something
more uh substantive than an ideology
well i think
genuine thinkers should ground their
world view in something more substantive
than an ideology and one of the things
that i've studied for a very long period
of time is is the relationship between
let's say ideologies or belief systems
for that matter to the underlying
psychological substructures that the
psychologist psychiatrist carl jung
described as archetypal and so you could
think of these archetypal
substructures as the grand stories by
which people conduct their lives and
they're they're
structured in a very particular way
they're very balanced stories
so for example
in a typical
properly constructed archetypal
narrative you have a represented
representation of nature or chaos or the
unknown those are symbolic categories
that are quite similar um they sort of
represent what exists beyond the safety
of the campfire and the town and the
city and and familiar territory you
could think about it as the archetype of
unexplored territory
and it's negative and positive at the
same time it's negative because you
better watch your step when you aren't
where you think you are because you'll
die if you're not careful right and
that's the negative element and so
nature can be a vicious brutal force and
everyone who's alive and thinks knows
that but by the same token it's also the
place the unknown in nature is the place
that you can go and explore and find new
and wonderful things go west young man
exactly that's exactly well and that's
an interesting one to bring up because
we'll we'll return to that we'll return
to that because there's a counter
narrative to that
so nature has its positive and negative
element it's often represented with
feminine symbols by the way mother
nature let's say
and then culture has the same structure
there's like the tyrannical king and the
benevolent king and the tyrannical king
is the part of culture that crushes you
and destroys you and mangles you and
forces you to be a cog in a wheel
and the benevolent part is the part that
educates you and disciplines you and
shelters you and teaches you to speak
and imbue you with all the
facets and traits that a civilized
person would have and again a story that
doesn't involve both of those forces is
incomplete
even though they're contradictory of
course and then
on top of that is the individual
and in an archetypal story the
individual has a heroic element and an
adversarial element and so in
christianity that's represented by the
say inter eternal conflict between
christ and satan if you're thinking
about it psychologically it's reflected
in the story of cain and abel as well
and in typical hostile brothers stories
very common narrative tropes and so
a comprehensive view of the world
offers a representation of all of those
elements
whereas an ideology what an ideology
does is slice that representation into a
partial formulation so for example
when feminists talk about the patriarchy
they essentially assume that
uh
the the social world is only a negative
force it's only tyrannical
well it is tyrannical but it's not only
tyrannical right and that that's true
we cannot force an only tyrannical
patriarchy on them
that's right that's exactly it there's
too much pushback right and i mean to
think about the the social structures in
the west as fundamentally tyrannical is
means that you're
uh either
well ideologically possessed to the
degree that's almost incomprehensible or
that you know absolutely nothing
whatsoever about history or the current
world for that and those may not be
mutually exclusive you may be
ideologically possessed
right well and you said go west young
man okay so so let me unravel out a bit
so there's a that's the frontier
narrative
so the frontier narrative is untamed
nature
positive culture
positive individual so it's the heroic
individual spreading the benefits of
benevolent culture into the wild untamed
wilderness
okay so that's an ideology and it's a
powerful one because it it draws on
these underlying archetypal symbolic
themes that are deeply motivational
meaningful to people but the counter
narrative emerged to that let's say that
was the narrative that settled the
united states
okay but the counter narrative emerged
and that's the environmental narrative
the environmental narrative is
benevolent nature
toxic culture
adversarial individual so the this
essential ideological environmental
narrative is terrible human beings that
are cancer on the planet are spreading
their toxic patriarchy and raping mother
nature
and i think it's no coincidence by the
way that the environmental movement as
we see it today
really sprung up in the 90s in the wake
of the fall of communism there was the
major ideology of the left that crumbled
before our eyes and now this new
ideology of environmentalism seems to
have largely taken its its uh position
of prominence
well see that okay so perhaps an
existing observation no i don't disagree
i don't disagree and i think it's
actually one of the things that really
pollutes the
argument about
environmental sustainability you know
like obviously
uh
exploiting the planet let's say in a way
that that produces unsustainable
externalized costs is a bad idea
clearly now the time frame matters but
it's clearly a bad idea the problem is
is that it's almost impossible to engage
in a discussion about environmental
sustainability without also
simultaneously engaging in a discussion
that's anti-capitalist
and so for me as soon as an
environmentalist becomes anti-capitalist
then i can't trust them as an
environmentalist because i don't know if
their environmentalism it usually is a
cover for their neo-marxism or or
another ideology that's precisely right
yeah it just pollutes the damn problem
and it's really about it well because
unintended
you can make a very strong case for a
conservative environmentalism
a conservationism sure yeah the word is
right there
that well exactly and and you know the
conservatives because part of the
conservative egg ethos is
try not to do anything too stupid
you know where's the you could say that
the liberal ethos is try actively to
improve things you know
and that's great act as stupidly as you
may yeah well in order to do it
well the problem is on the liberal end
of things and this is a temperamental
problem is that
uh many ideas that are designed to
generate solutions to problems actually
generate more problems
right and so
an informed conservative says something
like
well yeah there's a problem there
but let's not get ahead of ourselves and
presume that we actually know how to fix
it in a way that won't just make it
worse right right you know what and for
me like i'm kind of temperamentally
predisposed to be more on the liberal
left end of things from a personality
perspective because i'm high in a trait
called openness which is a good
predictor of of say liberalism and and
more left-wing thinking although i'm
also high in conscientiousness which is
a good predictor of more right-wing
thinking but
what really convinced me
to become more of a traditionalist i
would say was this realization of
unintended consequences
is that it's very very difficult to make
alterations to a complex system
in a manner that doesn't make the system
function worse instead of better
and so i think generally speaking that
especially when you're perturbing
extraordinarily complex social systems
that you should be
firmly aware of the limits of your
intelligence and the the probability of
your biased interpretations of course
and i love that you've brought up this
term traditionalism i actually made the
case a couple days ago that i think
donald trump himself maybe
counter-intuitively exhibits many
aspects of traditionalism in the edmund
burke michael oakshot sort of sense of
things and i wonder if now as you've
noted and channeling nietzsche that uh
you know at a certain point in our
culture god died for our cultural
purposes and ideology replaced it where
are we now are we in a post-ideological
age is god striking back against uh
nietzsche and his followers
well the thing is one of the things
that's really not necessary to note
about nietzsche is that when he made the
pronouncement that god was dead it was
by no means triumphant of course yeah so
people misunderstand that a lot oh
definitely the full phrase is is i'm
paraphrasing but the full phrase is
something like
god is dead
we have killed him and will never find
enough water to wash away the blood
right right right and and and that was
associated with thoughts he had at the
same time that the consequence of the
death of this traditional value
structure the idea of a transcendent
moral structure and and ultimate moral
responsibility would be replaced by two
things one would be a kind of hopeless
nihilism
and the other would be a swing
especially into leftist totalitarianism
which he directly predicted as did
dostoyevsky although that wasn't the
only
logical totalitarian outcome of course
so i mean he had that nailed it it's
actually one of the most amazing
prescient predictions that that i've
ever encountered you in in
your
description of ideology and your
description of traditionalism of symbols
of the symbolized of the logos as
transcendent and divine if i didn't know
any better i would guess that you were a
catholic you sound an awful lot like a
catholic and i wanted to know if you had
any thoughts about that description and
if you are not yet
well if you aren't yet a catholic can i
can i be your godfather eventually
orthodox i've been contacted by a number
of orthodox jews who think that i'm
pretty much an orthodox jew and a lot of
orthodox christians who think that i'm
pretty much an orthodox christian and
also a number of mormons who think or no
sorry not uh
no who were they
jehovah's witness can't remember
it's been funny it's because i've been
contacted by people from a lot of
different denominations and they and
they've said the same thing which is
that i'm putting the finger on what they
believe is at the core of their belief
system but you know and i've been
looking at this primarily from a
psychological perspective like i'm not
denying or even commenting on the
underlying metaphysical realities you
know technically speaking because it's
out sort of outside of my domain of
confidence i'm not denying their
existence or making a case for their
existence
on in my public presentations
but one thing i have discovered is that
there's something really fundamentally
important about the idea of the logos
you know because the logos is the idea
that
the individual
is
the the soul of the individual
and the value of that soul transcends
the value of the state
and that's an amazing proposition i
think that's the central western
proposition is that the state itself
has no
final dominion over the individuals
certainly right we may appeal to heaven
as general washington once put on a flag
so and the reason that that's so
psychologically significant as far as
i'm concerned is that the state and this
has been
realized by a number of cultures in a
variety of different ways the state has
a tendency to become too static right
and state and static or obviously the
same word and without the dynamic
consciousness of the individual
continually transforming expanding the
boundaries of the state
the state collapses into a type of
totalitarian rigidity and then everyone
dies
so if you don't keep the state
subservient in some sense to the free
consciousness and that's the moral
consciousness of the dedicated citizen
then everything goes to hell and and
very very rapidly and and almost
literally because i mean if you look at
places like you know stalinist soviet
union and especially in the 1930s and
mao's china and cambodia and these
places where these totalitarian systems
got the upper hand i mean to describe
them as hellish is an understatement i
would say so yeah it's a world of lies
it's a world of lies that wreaks havoc
in hell
well that's the other thing that's so
interesting is that the the really
informed commentators on those
totalitarian states have drawn a very
uh direct causal path between the
proclivity of the individual citizen to
falsify their own experience so to lie
by commission and omission and the
emergence of these totalitarian states
so what they essentially make isn't an
economic case or a political case they
make a psychological and ethical case
and that's especially well documented
well victor frankl does a pretty good
job of that in man's search for meaning
and vocal of havel made the same sort of
connection so did gandhi but i think
it's been best laid out
well partly by tolstoy who was a huge
influence on gandhi but most
particularly i would say by solzhenitsyn
in his documentations of the gulag
archipelago like his his entire
1700 page case is that
the reason that the totalitarian state
got the upper hand in the soviet union
was fundamentally because
too many citizens decided that it was in
their best short-term interest to lie
about everything including their own
suffering right july to themselves i i
think you put it one way i may have read
this from you or from someone else that
in to the utopian uh suffering is heresy
the acknowledgement of suffering is
heresy i know it's that well that's a
really great definition of hell a hell
is the place where you're in pain and
you're punished for admitting it
yeah you can't even admit it to yourself
of course and that there is we we have
all these discussions about which
pronouns we should use which bathrooms
people can use and they they seem to be
really uh highly politicized for
precisely this purpose they say it's
trivial it doesn't mean it's just a
little lie that we're telling each other
what's the big deal but
that that is the big deal when we live
in enough lies when we lie even about
our own suffering
you end up in a totalitarian state
well it's it's well and you're and
you're the totalitarian and you are yeah
that's precisely right you are the
oppressor right see i mean one of the
things that solzhenitsyn documents in
the gulag archipelago is his realization
that he was his own tyrant
you know and and it's so fascinating
because he wrote the gulag archipelago
when he was in the prison camps and he
basically memorized the book and that's
you know to to memorize the 1700 page
book is really something that is
uninconceivable especially a book like
that right and he didn't write the book
until he had was struck very hard by the
realization that he was
his ethical faults had directly
contributed to the situation that he
found himself in and you know
interestingly enough too he said that he
came to that realization in large part
although not solely by watching the very
few people that he saw in the prison
camps resist the
the the lie
the demand for lies on the part of their
jailers he said most of those people
were had a deeply rooted religious faith
and and that seemed to enable them to
refuse to cooperate with the authorities
when that cooperation was demanded which
would also preclude them partaking in
uh such roles as being camp trustees
because in the gulag system
interestingly enough
most of the positions of tyranny were
held by the prisoners themselves
which is now there is a great definition
of hell eh
hell is a prison where all the prison
guards are prisoners
that's precisely right
which actually i suppose is the
christian definition of hell certainly
milton's definition of hell
this does bring up another point which
is
if we are to
look at the man in the mirror and take
responsibility for ourselves and
recognize that much of our suffering and
our oppression is it comes from within
in our own ethical failures then i have
to ask this has been a meme going around
the internet for a long time do i really
have to clean up my room
well you don't have to but you have to
suffer the consequences
that's right i mean it's not a great
alternative
well that's the thing is that it's you
know it's it's in many situations in
life you get to pick your poison
right and that's really worthwhile
knowing because
it isn't that there's a pathway that you
can take that's going to make your life
well let's call it simple and happy
because life whatever life is it's not
simple enough it's certainly not those
things right no it's it's complex and
tragic
and you can
ennoble that
with a certain mode of being and and
that mode of being has to be associated
with
a willingness to abide by the truth and
like i don't even really think about
these things as ethical commandments in
some sense i and and it's something
that's also struck me as as a i've
become more and more familiar with
biblical writings is that
most of the time they're simple
statements of fact
so
imagine you know reality has a structure
it's complex and you can tell it has a
structure because it punishes you very
badly when you do some things you
shouldn't do like you know toddlers
learn very rapidly not to stand up
underneath tables when they're first
learning to walk don't touch the burner
on the stove exactly and the table is
always hard and the burner always burns
and so you can learn to avoid those
things because they're you know they're
cut and dried their walls
but
now unfortunately i've lost my train of
thought that's fine i when i imagine the
suffering of every time i push the
burner that also makes me lose it as
well i would like to
yes okay well the thing is is that
those those elements of suffering are
are built into the structure of the
world the structure of the world is real
and the problem with lying is that you
replace
uh accurate perception of the structure
of the world with a wish an arrogant
wish like the wish is that you could
have things the way that you want them
on my character
that's exactly it the arrogant part is
on my terms and all get away with it and
it's such an absurd proposition because
the probability that you can bend the
structure of reality in your favor
without it having it snap back and hit
you in the face which is i suppose in
some sense a definition of god in in a
perverse ways it's zero right like in my
clinical practice and i swear that this
is the case and and i would say also in
my private life observing people over
long periods of time
i have never seen anyone get away with
anything
they s it always comes back to haunt
them in one form or another and they may
not
realize or understand the causal
connections sometimes that's what
psychotherapy is about
but the causal connections are there and
that's the sort of thing that
solzhenitsyn detailed in the gulag
archipelago
now it's so weird because he was he was
a victim of hitler because he was on the
front lines and then he was a victim of
stellan
and i mean if if you want to make a case
for being a victim
he had a rough go of it
that's for sure right and but instead he
decided that he was going to take the
responsibility on himself
and become one of the greatest men of
the century right well that's that's the
thing that's so
incomprehensible is that that book was
that really was there was a few death
blows to the integrity of the communist
system but from an articulated and
and and and verbal perspective an
intellectual perspective nothing topped
the gulag archipelago it it took the
substructure out from underneath any
moral claim that communism had just a
glimpse of reality does it i do i know i
said that was the last question but i
actually have one more do you this is a
very practical question
four
uh
young people or people who are wandering
around in these
shallow ideologies and this sort of
nihilism living in lies
whatever you want to call it what advice
would you give to them is it go worship
god does it read the bible is it accept
the tragic fact of life how can they
pull themselves out of the mire and wash
all that blood off of us that nietzsche
said we'd never get off
well you know carl jung said something
that that is quite similar to
solzhenitsyn's prescription which was
that
with a sufficient moral effort
psychoanalysis was unnecessary
i would say that
the best advice that
that i might give to people
is that they try to stop saying things
that make them weak
which is a variant of trying to learn
not to lie because if you pay attention
if you pay attention nietzsche said who
among us has never sacrificed himself
for the sake of his good name
and what he meant by that was well you
know you're in a social circumstance and
you
act in a manner that's different than
how you actually feel or you refuse to
put forward your viewpoint or you can't
or you know you falsify yourself and
some of that you know
is akin to being socialized let's say
but put that aside i'm thinking about
the falsification part it's like if you
watch yourself very carefully if you
watch what you say and i would include
your non-verbal behavior in that
category you'll see that certain things
that you say put solid ground under your
feet and certain things turn the ground
that you're standing on into quicksand
and you can feel that in an embodied
sense it's something carl rogers who's a
great psychiatrist psychologist um
realized quite i guess probably in the
50s or the 40s and that there was an
embodied sense and in some sense that
would be equivalent to the voice of
conscience and so you know when you're
betraying yourself you know when you're
weakening yourself and if you start to
pay attention to that
you can learn to stop doing that
it's interesting because i was just
reading socrates apology which is his
the description of his the trial that
eventually ended in his death and his
reaction to that his heroic reaction to
that and
he talked about the thing that
differentiated him from other people
and he said well he had this internal
voice which he called a demon
obviously is related to the word demon
right it wasn't that it's an internal
spirit an internal voice
and he always listened to it and he
never told him what to do
but it told him what not to do
and so if the internal voice objected to
something he was doing or saying he
would stop he would stop doing it he
would stop doing it he'd reformulate it
and so the reason he didn't defend
himself at his trial interestingly
enough is because his internal voice and
leave because really they just wanted
him to get the hell out of athens
because he was a troublemaker so they
warned him long ahead that he was going
to be tried and found guilty essentially
and his friends told him to leave and he
went and consulted his damon and it said
no don't don't leave
and he thought like well
what what the hell
yeah exactly and then he thought it
through and he thought well he was
getting very old and
and maybe the gods had granted him the
opportunity to
step out of life gracefully and put his
affairs in order and so on you know i
mean you can think about it as a
rationalization but it was socrates that
we're talking about so i wouldn't do
that too quickly of course but
i must say my my internal voice is
telling me not to end this interview for
several more hours because it is just so
illuminating and i could talk to you all
day long but unfortunately the voice of
ben shapiro in the next room saying that
we need to uh close off the show is the
one that writes my check so uh
unfortunately uh we'll we'll have to end
it here dr peterson thank you so much
for coming on this has been a wonderful
discussion and i hope that we can have
you back
thanks a lot for the invitation and for
the discussion
[Music]
[Music]
you